[Music]
hello YouTube chess Louis and my friends
this is grunge in here welcome to the
43rd episode of my dirty chess tricks
this is a two-part video guys and in my
first video I'm going to show you some
of the wonderful tricks and traps exist
in the three nights variation where in
my next video I will do the same for the
four nights variation the opening arises
after the following model E 4 E Phi
Knight to f3 Knight to c6 and by far
here the most popular choice by white is
to play royal pace with Bishop to b5 or
to play Joko piano with Bishop to c4
however in this video we are going to
start the third big alternative for
white namely Knight to c3 now as the
name suggests we have three nights on
the board and at first sight White's
last move looks completely innocent and
harmless as it blocks his own C pawn
right but here comes the vital point as
even though black has plenty of choices
only specific moves are the right way to
move further with specially below mm not
many people are finding it more often
recently I have included this in my
recruiter and I have tremendous success
ratio with it so let's join with me and
find out how tricky this opening is
against various black replies let's
start with the dark square bishop moves
so the first obvious move which many
Italian player play at this position is
Bishop to c5 as it
more often played against Bishop to c4
but here just within third mu of the
game black has made a blunder and I
can't tell you how often I have to face
this response and every time I give my
opponent this rude shock BAM ha ha ha ha
so just within opening White has
completely destroyed black Center and
even though black has two choices
neither of them give any satisfaction
position for the black camp the first
move very obvious what happens if black
captured this night where the simplest
replies you played the Moody for getting
your piece back and after Bishop to d6
pawn capture signify Bishop captures
ePHI and the mu f for white has
conformed his space in the center of the
ball and not only there later on White
will get a tremendous attack on the
black King the baseline run as follows
black should capture on c3 so that way
black and give white this CC pawn but
even though position is quite good for
white as white has thus two bishops and
a space in the center which give him
ample attacking activity on the Kings
side for example a simple line can run
like this
d6 so black liberate his light square
bishop white should continue with the
shock to see food and after Queen to f6
which looks more natural in this
position attacking on c3 white can
defend his c3 pawn with Queen to d4 if
Queen exchange then white pawn structure
will be repaired
so initially black wants to avoid it and
accordingly Queen to g6 is a fitting
reply attacking on g2 but after castle
on the Kings side White has completed
almost his piece development
and he's already threatening the MU
fi-ware on the counter part black has
the only piece developed and that is
Queen the second reply Bishop captures
f2 is very obvious and many low ranked
player afraid of this because they think
that their King has been exposed but
after the continuation Knight captures
Aoife and the moody fall once again you
can see the space white is gaining on
the center of the board
and if black gives any of this Jack then
white can safely negotiate it so here
the best reply goes with Knight to g6
afterwards white can continue with Queen
to f3 after some initial reply d6
liberating the light square bishop as
you can see I have highlighted the
simple but effective plan of campaign by
white white can play the move Bishop to
d3 rook to a fun and then put his King
safely on g7 where he get a tremendous
attack on the black King side and not to
forget what has this impressive pawn
which is always going to give a cramping
effect to the black game so after Bishop
to c5 black enter into the positional
trap where what can destroy a black
center and get a very good attacking
game the second more I want to consider
is Bishop to b4 which is rarely played
but still we need to know what we are
going to do about it
here my recommendation is you should
play Knight to d5 and attacking the
bishop
if white can get the bishop pair then in
the long run black is going to suffer so
accordingly black has to preserve his
dark squared bishop if Bishop to c5 then
you already know what to do yep it's
boom-boom time Knight to be Phi and the
same trick works here as well
so after night to defy the obvious
choice for the black is to play Bishop
to e5 keeping his option open but I
think this is already a small mistake as
White has a very strong reply here c3
the big idea behind this move can be
revealed after black's next obvious
choice Knight to f6 which hitting two
sports but here comes the whole point
white lash out with d4 attacking the
black centre and accordingly your Black
has two good replies the first move he
kept his d4 is a pretty bad one the
simple reason is after the move before
attacking the bishop Bishop to b6 and
now a very strong move Bishop to g5 so
white is all set to give black double
pawn on the F file and look at this dark
square bishop it has been completely
misplaced on top of everything where is
the threat of efore something which
black has to pay attention immediately
as in one game black become greedy and
capture on c3 which at first sight looks
so attractive because at this point
black is a to pawn up right but the
perception can be deceptive as white
continues wait 'if i attacking the
knight at six doesn't work here and i
leave it to find it by yourself
but black has the another idea and i
think he was relying on this move Bishop
captures f2 so that if white foolishly
captured the bishop the Knight to e4
regained the piece with an interest
however what black mist is this simple
looking move king to e2 and now black is
definitely losing piece the second move
Knight captures efore is not good either
the simple reason is after pawn captures
ePHI that night is trapped at the center
of the ball
Knight to C Phi is not a location as
before we'll trap the piece so black has
to somehow destroy white Center the
baseline goes as follows
d6 trying to undermine the white center
white place Queen to c2 attacking the
knight and black has the only response
to sail the knight and that is fi
afterwards
white will take this and percent and
when black recapture with denied can you
guess why it's next reply yup it's very
obvious of a typical theme Bishop to g5
pinning down the f6 Knight giving black
a shattered pawn on the Kings side and
in this variation you can even Castle
long and start attacking which can be
turned out very little for the black ink
the third move I want to consider it is
Bishop to e7 which can be played by many
hungarian defense player but against
Knight to c3 this is not a right move as
after the simple reply Bishop to b5
which we are going to see more often in
this opening the idea is very simple we
want to capture on c6 and then capture
on e5
so black response is almost forced he
has to play the move d6 afterwards we
will continue with this theme attic
break default threatening to play d5 or
capture on ePHI so more or less black is
forced to capture this pawn afterwards
white will recapture with the night
realizing c6 so again black responds his
force he has to play Bishop to d7 and
now we are going to simply cancel on the
Kings side after the most obvious
response Knight to f6
White is going to capture on c6 if
Bishop to c6 then Knight to fi is very
strong reply so black should capture
with the power
afterwards White has this tricky move in
this position
Bishop to f4 the whole point is when
black castle on the kingside white
intend to play the movie Phi if Knight
to d5 the Knight captures defer is a
very strong reply and after the best
replies suggested by the engine he
captures e5 pressure captures ePHI
although material is balanced black has
this shattered pawn structure on the
Queen side which are more than enough to
exploit and win the game so this is one
of the wonderful trick exist when your
opponent plays Bishop to e7 that is one
important point I like to mention before
we go to the next move
if the opponent plays Bishop to d6 then
do not capture on d6 and repair black
pawn structure but I should play the
move Bishop to g3 and I have attached a
model game in the PGN which will give
you a very good idea black position can
crumble from this point on the fourth
more I want to consider is d6
which is again very popular at the club
level but after the move Bishop to b5
black is having some great difficulties
if Knight to f6 or Bishop to e7 then it
will transpose to the line which we
already look at it so the only
independent move over here is Bishop to
g4 pinning down the f3 Knight but
because White has pinned at c6 Knight
this variation is completely harmless I
like to show you one of my game which
will give you a very good idea how
easily white get winning position this
is my game against the 2008 HCM where I
continue with very logically d4 putting
pressure in the center of the board
black pawns is almost force he has to
capture on
oh by the way if he had played the move
Bishop captures f3
then it still leads to the same position
which we are about to see okay he
captures default Queen captures d4 black
cannot play Bishop to e7 so he continued
with a6 asking my bishop what he wants
to do well I obviously capture on c6 my
opponent recapture and now comes the
same question to the black side ash-tree
what you are going to do next if Bishop
has been dropped back then white will
castle on the Kings side and once again
these structural weaknesses can be a
headache from the black perspective so
my opponent decided to give me double
pawn on the F file with Bishop captures
f3 and G captors f3
okay Knight to f6 what else and now I
continue with developing move Bishop to
e3 if Bishop to e7 then Roop to g1 can
be very lethal for the black so
accordingly
my opponent find the best route to
develop his bishop he continued with in
g6 and after I Castle long Bishop to g7
is obvious response so far blacks
position looks so good right but after
White's next reply Queen to c4 I think
game is or why well obvious thing is
white is hitting on c6 and there is no
good way to defend except Queen to c7
afterwards White has this little reply
ePHI attacking to sports and black has
the only good reply Knight to d5
afterwards what will take this night and
after pawn takes and Queen takes we are
checking the rook in the same time
hitting on d6 my opponent decided to
castle on the Kings side but after pawn
captures pawn captures instead of
grabbing the d6 and giving
blaka counterplay I decided to exchange
more pieces with very nice move Bishop
to d4 completely neutralizing any attack
from the black the game concluded very
quickly after Bishop captures before
rook captures d4 rook to d8 defending on
d6 but after the move h4 not only white
emerged with a two-point advantage but
on top of everything white can decide
where he wants to go he can play the
move rook to d1 and pressure on D file
or the other plan is continue with h5
and then launch a devastation on the
King side or all I think if your
opponent continue with four Bishop g4
then you should more than happy as
resulting position are quite favorable
to the white side v more I want to
consider is F Phi which is known as
Gothic defense and if you don't know
much about this then you might end up on
the trouble line however here what has a
very strong reply d4 so keeping the
tension in the center and black has two
choices now by far F captures efore is a
main line however if your opponent
continues sweet he kept his default then
after Knight captures default attacking
on a fight twice so black responds his
force black has to capture on e4
afterwards we are going to continue with
night capture c6 d capture c6 and now
the star mu Queen to h4 check if g6 then
Queen to e5 NAB the rook in the corner
so by force black has to move the King
and after some attacking moves Bishop to
g5 if Bishop to e7 then castle on the
Queen side will NAB the Queen so by
force black has to move the Queen
afterwards we are going to castle on the
queenside and black and hardly survive
from such positions okay then let's see
what happens if black continue with the
main line f kept us evil
well after that white response is very
obvious we are going to capture on e5
and now in the view of night captures
evil black response is almost force he
has to play Knight to f6 saving on e4
and also stopping Queen to h5 check but
then he has to deal with another threat
Bishop to c4
so something nasty is coming on f7 and
the only way to prevail this is to play
the Moon D Phi which at first sight
looks very obvious stopping all White's
attack but after White's next reply
black and literally back is back and go
home well yup guys the ball is in your
court before I move on I like you to
pause this video and find out that
little reply well I hope you find this
deciding blow
unbelievable right
but yup it's true let's see what's the
whole point after Knight captures D Phi
well not so surprising why it has this
forcing sequence Queen to h4 check g6
Knight captures g6 if Knight to f6 at
this point then Bishop grab 7 is a very
strong reply as after King captures f7
and Knight to e5 black King can hardly
survive from this position for example
if King to e6 then we have Queen 12:7
checked and no matter wherever the King
goes the mate will follow soon
so accordingly here black has to capture
this night and give up the exchange but
we are not interested in the exchange
rather we are interested in tickling the
black King with Queen captures g6 okay
King to d7 and now very simple Bishop
captures g7 and even though white is a
piece down in this position White has a
3 connected pawn on the Kings side and
on top of every team right now
what is threatening Queen captures g6
something black needs to parry
immediately to give you a taste of this
line I like to show you one online game
between two strong FM where black
continued with Knight captures d4
pairing a threat as well as attacking on
c2 white continues with Bishop to g5
attacking the Queen Queen to e8 is
obvious response trying to exchange the
Queen and accordingly white stop it
faith Bishop to m7 attacking the Queen
Queen to e5 and now very nice move rook
to d1 threatening c3 so black continue
with Bishop to d6 unpinning denied but
then white regain the piece with Bishop
gripstics attacking to sports night to
see to happen on the ball but white
calmly played King to d2 and after few
moves force black to resign the game
last but not least what happens if black
continued with the moon g6
which is again one of the most popular
choice by black however against this my
recommendation is you start with the
moon d4 a checking on e5 if Bishop to g7
then Bishop to g4 is a very strong reply
so by force
black has to capture on d4
afterwards rather than regaining your
porn I'm going to propose this very
tricky move Knight to d5
the idea is very obvious after the
natural move Bishop to g7 which defend
on d4 White has this very aggressive
reply Bishop to g5 if f6 then Bishop
twedge four is a very strong reply and
if you open and find the best move
Knight C to e7 then my recommendation is
you continue with Knight captures d4
regaining your material and the
resulting position is quite favorable to
the right I have a catch a model game in
the PGN which will give you a very good
idea how to play from there onwards
however more often you will find that
your opponent will continue with Knight
G to e7 which is a more natural move in
this position defending every threat and
ready to castle on the Kings side well
everything looks so good except one
problem that blacks last move is a big
time disaster and before I move on I
like you to pause this video and find a
continuation where white is completely
winning
okay then let's start the first
surprising movies night capped is d4 so
idea is very simple we want to capture
this night and then capture on e7 and
trapping the black Queen and if black
continue it night captures default then
again we can't capture on e7 and nab the
black queen but the big question arise
what happens if black take with the
bishop which is very obvious in this
position diffusing all white threats
well here comes the answer and I think I
have covered one of the similar line
from the English opening in my queen
traps a kleine part two video and here
what has this dazzling Queen sacrifice
yup Queen captures d4 boom hahaha
obviously black cannot capture the
screen the simple reason is after Knight
to f6 King to f8 and Bishop to at six
black king is going to be checkmated so
that's not a good option and other move
which more often played in this position
castle on the Kings side again leads to
the mage after Knight to f6 check King
to h8 and now very strong move Knight to
g4 and the mate is inaudible as after f6
Bishop f6 rook up six Queen up six King
G H and the smoothest mage night to at
six that's it guys I hope you enjoy and
learned a small informative video on
three Knights variation in my next video
I'm going to concentrate on the move
Knight to f6 afterwards we are going to
continue with Bishop to b5 and we will
see some nice tricks in this line as
well well thank you for watching this
video feel free to like subscribe
and comment and I'll meet you in my next
episode very soon bye and take care